come on you know kyle's my friend and
there's nobody that likes and believes
in kyle moore when you guys get together
again like is it right back to the old
texas days and reminiscing oh you see
this picture oh my gosh what is this do
you remember us having like so many
pimples and stuff on this i thought no
that was the first thing i thought we
were cool i've made a promise to myself
that i will not be picking against the
49ers really for the rest of the year
i'm going to take some credit for the
49ers i haven't talked to kyle in months
okay he doesn't want to talk to me i'm
johnny media to him right i don't want
to talk to you either yeah we'll deal
with it
chris sims mike florio pro football talk
live and we're here in california and
chris sims and kyle shanahan go way back
how old were you when you met cal the
first time i believe i was 19 19 he
transferred from duke
our first meeting was really like a real
tough conditioning workout at texas
right we're you know it's the off season
we're getting ready for the sophomore
sophomore year now in the middle of your
freshman year basically and we hit it
off right right from get-go we really
did he was a receiver you were a
quarterback passed you through to him in
practice did you complete it i i think i
did you know he was like before his time
he had a little talent at receiver like
i do think if he
was in college football maybe six seven
eight years later that he would have
been a little more valued unbelievable
route runner i mean he really was the
team listened to everything he said
about rat running because he was
obsessed with it that's why his offense
is so good he really sees the offense
through the wide receiver's eyes like
what would i want to do if i was a wide
receiver how would i get the ball to the
wide receiver and i think it's very
interesting but he was a great route
runner and he you know worked with ed
mccaffrey and rod smith because of his
dad and all of that and really taught a
lot of our other texas receivers little
nuances about route running well and now
he is a great coach in addition to being
a great route runner and his team in
kyle's third season as a head coach in
the nfc division around the number one
seed in the conference at home
santa clara levi's stadium facing the
vikings on saturday and we'll be there
as part of football night in america
we'll be there to watch the game we'll
be on the sideline chris will be
standing close to the white stripe and
hopefully get shoved by an official like
last year but we got to talk about that
game and
the the 49ers seven point favorites not
a surprise they've been one of the best
teams all year long the vikings are a
mixed bag you never really know who's
going to show up in any given week and i
think we'll know by them i'd say the
middle of the second quarter sure we'll
know whether or not the vikings are are
on or not right well yeah we we felt
that last week right i think after the
first drive or two we went all right
minnesota looks like they're going
around when they stiffened after the
fumble and only gave up a field goal
you're right match the field goal that's
when we thought okay this could be this
could be a game at least you're right
and i still didn't think they would win
at that point the game got to 10-6 and i
went oh the saints got the ball here
they go they're going to give the death
blow they got the interception they went
down to score a touchdown but uh i think
of course minnesota do they pose some
problems for kyle shanahan and the san
francisco team certainly i mean hey
listen their defense you know what's
talented they got speed on the edge they
got two linebackers who are you know pro
bowl caliber type of football players
they got two really good safeties in the
back end so you know it's going to be
big i really look at this as like okay
everson griffin deneill hunter the two
backers in the middle congratulations i
got it right i got it those two those to
me are the people you need to focus on
in this game because shanahan not only
the run game all the trick stuff he does
as far as movement reverses play action
passes and you don't want to be blitzing
and over committing certain guys to
certain areas because that's what will
lead you to getting gashed and that was
what helped them win last week can they
pull it off again this week i don't know
the 49ers offense
is more explosive than the saints and
that's what scares me i guess a little
bit more for the vikings defense let's
apply the bill belichick approach to
both teams right both offenses right
let's start with the vikings offense our
defense rather right what do you do as
the minnesota defense what do you take
away what what does the 49ers offense do
best that you try to shut down i think
you do have to stop the run first i you
know and and this is it's weird to say
that this day and age because of course
it's such a passing league but if you
can stymie shanahan's run game to a
degree
it will slow down the rest of the great
stuff he has you know you just talked
about like sean payton drew brees
they're surgical right it's just like
they're snipers
okay we're picking you apart for eight
ten yards kyle's one of those guys where
it's like oh i got him in the defense i
want watch out
80 yard touchdown that's what he tries
to do he goes for the kill that way so i
do think the run game is imperative for
the vikings to at least slow it down
because then it doesn't open up all the
trickery that shanahan can bring the
play actions deep down the field george
kittle and all the tricky things they do
with him so
it's the run game but if you maybe pick
one player i'm going kiddle i mean
kittle is the guy i think you got to
take away and the vikings do have the
assets to make that tough and i agree
with you i think the more they can force
quarterback jimmy garoppolo to have to
throw to his outside guys and take their
chances that maybe he'll be inaccurate
maybe it just won't be his day we don't
know what kind of a day it's going to be
for jimmy garoppolo because he's never
played in a playoff game yeah and he
faced the vikings once it was the start
of the 2018 season first game and that
was a lifetime ago but there's still
some lines you can connect between that
game in this game same defense same
coaches yeah quarterback a lot of the
same personnel he had three
interceptions that day one went back for
a touchdown career low quarterback
rating of 45.1
and you just wonder how much of that was
studied this week by the vikings
defensive staff to think about what
maybe can be done that was done in that
game or or and this is where it goes
next level yeah what kind of look can
you show that may make garoppolo think
it's going to be the same thing it was
in that game but it's going to be
something different no doubt i think
that's what really to me you know if i'm
playing kyle shanahan you know the
genius of kyle is when he knows he gets
into a certain formation and he can pin
you to oh they play this defense when
i'm in this formation that's when he can
become the mad scientist and draw up
plays that totally just screw you over
and you're right zimmer's got to give
different looks he better self-scout
thyself going into this week shanahan
with two weeks off and not only that the
creativity and his you know for lack of
a better phrase guts to do plays that
have not been called before
my big thing too would be
okay yes we know zimmer needs to slow
down kyle shanahan the other thing is
though if i'm mike zimmer i'm going into
kevin stefanski and kubiak this week
going hey guys this offense is legit
like we might need to push the envelope
this week we got to continue to push the
bar here and be creative we saw some
things last week they were pretty
creative from their offense can they
continue to expand on that if 49ers are
hot early right it's up and down the
field
i don't want you know the vikings can't
be looking up going man it's 17 nothing
and we haven't really gotten the flow
yet they're going to have to match some
of that energy and explosiveness on the
offensive side how many plays will kyle
have in his
game plan that he intends to use and how
many other plays are available if he
spots something in a formation and tells
garoppolo
right all this play instead yeah right
uh well he's different than like john
gruden where we would go into a game
with like 160 180 plays on the menu kyle
condenses it a little bit more to where
okay i know i like these uh and i would
bet you when it's all said and done
shanahan kyle's probably around 120 100
plays somewhere in that version because
you always have to have those fail-safe
plays too right oh george kittle's out
now i got to play a different personnel
and i got to kind of go and dive into
that so he's got all those type of
things
for the just in case plan but you know
the thing i love about kyle is the and
the offense in general is it's not a
rolodex offense it's not just like oh i
like this fight this is
i like this play no he has a plan on
what he likes and what he wants to
attack uh tactically against that scheme
and he tries to expose it that way
interesting note from raheem mostert
49ers running back meeting with
reporters explaining that jerick
mckinnon who signed with the 49ers he
was one of their first marquee free
agent pickups he hasn't done anything
because of a torn acl that got torn
again he was very good with the vikings
not great but very good very good he's
been letting 49ers teammates know things
about how certain defensive players play
and i don't know how much of a benefit
it is but it is somebody who was part of
that team that made it to the nfc
championship two years ago that does
have some ins and some intelligence sure
behind the curtain type stuff that sure
can make a difference no
any little advantage you can find
whether he's telling you know a wide
receiver oh xavier rhodes doesn't like
to defend this route he always
complained about it in practice or you
know anthony barr has an issue with this
type of movement when you're a running
back running out of the back field yeah
there'll be little nuances that those
guys can lean on i think the biggest
thing is it'll just make people feel
comfortable it humanizes the other team
to go like wait this isn't scary this is
a big number 55 like this you know
jerick told us in the locker room he's a
good dude all week and he's got issues
with this whatever it may be i look at
more the tactical stuff with the kubiak
cousins shanahan factor that to me is
where it's more interesting you're
talking about gary kubiak former broncos
and texans head coaches right lloyd kyle
shanahan right now the assistant head
coach offensive consultant for the
vikings and kirk cousins drafted by
washington when mike and kyle shanahan
and cousins played for kyle shanahan and
you're right where is that advantage
between what kyle knows about kubiak and
cousins and what kubiak and cousins know
about kyle right and i think the
advantage is i think cousins probably
knows more about kyle than kubiak kubiak
i do think we'll be able to tell max
zimmer hey kyle hey likes to run when we
play this defensive front he likes to
run this play he'll be able to give him
little nuance looks like that where kirk
cousins could be dangerous and if i was
mike zimmer i would have picked his
brain for sure is of course cousins was
in a meeting room every day
six seven hours a day with kyle shanahan
as he's teaching reads to the pass game
and you know kyle really simplifies it
for his quarterbacks at times he
literally has plays where he just goes
listen drop back stare at this guy and
if he goes this way throw it to that guy
if he goes that way throw it to this guy
and that's all there is to the play you
don't need to look at anything else i'm
going to design it to where it makes it
real easy on you and those are the
little things that maybe kirk cousins
can shed a little light on to mike
zimmer to where maybe he can change it
up or or not be so predictable it's a
fascinating dynamic today's nfl when you
consider
when you are part of a team and you are
striving toward a common goal anything
you say and do within the confines of
what you're trying to achieve with that
team right can and will be used against
you at some point in the future no
pieces scatter elsewhere the really good
coaches don't teach their assistants
really their great tricks and their
little nuances to what makes them great
that may explain why all of bill
belichick's assistants fail well i think
there is some truth to that and when we
heard bill when we heard josh mcdaniel
say hey last year i didn't go to
indianapolis because you know we heard
the rumors that bill was going to open
the vault for him and let him really
know i mean that tells you i mean josh
has been one of the most trusted members
of the staff and bill wasn't letting him
know all the tricks of the trade and you
know i think you know yes there is that
that goes on even when i was in new
england i feel like some of our
offensive staff didn't really know how
josh operated to make the game plan you
know because josh would lock himself in
a room and i don't think he wanted to
let everybody know like oh this is how i
come up with this so you can what come
back and screw me with it three years
from now or whatever it may be so
amazing amazing that's how they do with
everything they do personnel they do it
with coaching to do with everything they
know that there will be future seasons
future games future contests like
playoff matchups where you're going to
have these old relationships that come
together again so when the vikings face
the 49ers on
saturday at levi's stadium there's a
chance it's going to be close late
there's a chance yes that is going to
come down to who can make the big throw
and
i still am undecided on whether or not
the two big throws that kirk cousins
made in overtime exercise the demons
yeah i hear you because this is the
first time all year long that they ended
up beating a team that has a winning
record when they beat the saints on
sunday and mike zimmer
is selling it as
the busting through a ceiling by kirk
cousins i'll believe it when i see it
right but but i got to give him credit
the 43-yard pass to adam thielen a thing
of beauty by both guys that's guy who
threw it in the guy who caught it yes
and the last play of the game if you
watch that closely this snap was not a
great no anybody he had to get it he had
to readjust he had to throw it without
thinking about it so i don't know does
that give him the confidence see that
see how he almost bobbled the snap got
the throw off i i i just wonder and
we're gonna find out saturday does that
get him past the moments where he's kind
of got a little deer in the headlights
in the past well yeah i mean listen i
think he's a very uh aware person
self-aware aware of what's being said
yeah probably too aware and i can
understand that because i think i had
moments in my career where i felt like i
was too aware of walking to the walk
breaking in the huddle in a big moment
going whoa this is a big moment instead
of just going hey what the hell do i
gotta do what are you playing past that
yeah
how can you just gotta continue to beat
it in your brain i do think last week
will give him confidence nonetheless
just go hey wait i can do this in a big
moment in a tough spot whatever that may
be i proved that i can answer the bell
now do they get those opportunities to
the one-on-one shots down the field and
like that because i know i don't always
rely on staffan ski to make things
easier on them and i just drop my mic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports